so my son's left cookies and milk on his
bedside table how do i tell him that
santa is lactose intolerant
like do i just drink the milk and take
the shits for my son how do i leave it
there and break his heart
i remember one time my dad was like no
no no connor santa likes beer
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste i am your host for today
gigguk
and with me are the usual boys and today
we have a very special guest with us
no one it's just it's just me today i
finally i thought you're about to be
like we have a very special guest
me by myself it's gigguk the anime zone
and steve handjobs who has been left at
home today
but uh yeah he did wear a towel now i
did i did not wear a tail tonight today
and uh in the christmas spirit i brought
you guys gift you can get me
oh can't believe it so this is this is
apparently going to be our christmas
special
it's not it's not this is this christmas
this is this is our christmas special
that we
are not recording christmas holy [ __ ]
you actually wrapped it up
yeah sure i i wrapped it up by the way
merry christmas because i think this
should be airing on a boxing day
right yeah yeah do americans have boxing
day maryland do americans have boxing
day
okay no they don't know boxing day is
the day after christmas day yeah
okay there's cherries right so they may
they may be writing on the
on the thing right so the box is fine so
you can open it up right right but they
may be writing on the thing
in japanese jerry ignore it don't read
it just
okay you can open just open the box now
but we
went inside i think there'll be a label
on it just don't read the label joke
okay
it might be in kanji so okay well i
can't read it anyway
i'm all good but yeah to explain what
boxing day is isn't boxing day
the actual day you were meant to open
your presents i don't [ __ ] like
isn't that why it's called boxing day is
that what it is yeah i think i think
that's why it's called
just the day you ate all the leftovers i
always thought boxing day was like an
event where like everyone like
boxes oh so it's like oh it's a little
music box
so don't open yours yet right okay i
can't you
might want to play it up to the
microphone okay everyone needs to be
silent
let me let me let me guess the song yeah
guess the song
[Music]
is this your name yes
oh my god thank you so much where'd you
get this i think i know exactly where
you built this from
all right i'm not going to look at that
look at the label joe
i got joey something too all right i
have to wait for yours to shut up wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait let's
let's nightcore zenzenzen
just stops it huh i think it just stops
it all right
[Music]
that's also your name right yeah it's
the same band right yeah it's red
williams yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
it's the ending because joey always
sings a song karaoke
i don't know if you can hear it in the
background but it's just going on now i
shouldn't have winded it so much
yeah so yeah boxing days day after
christmas
do you have boxing day in australia yeah
yeah we do
this is so i don't know if the mic is
picking you up as loud as [ __ ] in this
room right now
actually i think i know exactly what you
guys yeah yeah because i bought one
as well oh did you yeah is it like
ghibli ones as well yeah yeah but i saw
anime songs and i was like i should buy
anime songs for the boys
i got one uh i got one actually which
was like a vulpix
from uh pokemon yeah yeah that was
really good this is an awesome gift
though
yeah there you go i could easily give
this to all my friends you're welcome
boys thanks so much
thank you thank you very much thank you
i'll get your presents soon don't worry
it's not like we literally just decided
this was the christmas episode
the day of recording yeah we didn't know
this was going to be the christmas
episode
i just thought i'd bring a gift you know
i'll be nice you know i saw it wow it's
really good
it's just [ __ ] going it just keeps
going doesn't it really do you want to
have this for now
yeah do you want to hold on to this just
get it off screen
yeah put it outside my desk it should be
fine
yeah turn off naturally don't turn it
anymore yeah just leave it just
just let it just let it sit on the desk
it'll be fine yeah but i know exactly
where you got those from because
you took a trip didn't you i did i did i
went up to hokkaido but
it's all good you should chill a little
vacation yeah jackson is nice every
every youtuber needs a vacation every
now and again all their food
food's amazing i told you they've
optimized the food right it's good man
it's good
it's as good as everyone says it is you
should go go if you get the chance
what are some like uh like specific
dishes that you had up there that you
would recommend to people who want to go
to hokkaido
anything with milk in it it's just like
yeah is does it meet the hype
yes i've heard so much about hokkaido
milk and what is what is so good about
the milk there
it's like the breed of cow i don't know
man it's just rich it's real rich
it's like full cream right yeah and i
had like a milk ice cream i don't know
me like
milk ice cream but it was just like
intense milk hit you yeah
i saw you posted a picture of like beer
ice cream as well
oh yeah yeah yeah just just to prove
that japan does every flavor of soft
serve i don't know why you'd ever want
beer ice cream yeah there was like ice
cream that was just
beer and i was like i mean sure i'll try
it i like both these things individually
even alcoholics are like
i can't imagine a beer flavored anything
it's aside from
beer and it tastes like a ski ice cream
yeah what's that what's the weirdest
flavor of ice cream you've had
rum rate i'm sure i don't know how dare
you
probably
they do that [ __ ] here with food they're
like i don't care about the boundaries
i like both these things let's make it
into food that's that's like the
equivalent of [ __ ] what's what some
americans do which like buying of
mcflurry and then just dipping it with
fries okay which just
blows my mind okay but actually i kind
of like that no no
no no what it's pretty good i went to i
i
did [ __ ] aki took me to a steak and
shake once which is where like
the optimal place of where you do that
and i just saw like six americans
dipping their fries
into their shakes i'm just like i can't
i can't be here i have to leave we're
living in a first world country dude why
why why are you eating like this
honestly like i don't do it often but it
tastes pretty good when i've done it you
know
i don't get it it's like oh it's like a
nice it's it's the synergy of the
saltiness i see the fries and i don't
understand why it works it just does
right it doesn't also steak and shakes
like the most depressing place in
america
like i i went to one at like midnight
because i was like yeah maybe it's
because you went at midnight
there was a dollar fifty burgers yeah
yeah yeah yeah jesus christ
i don't know you've never you've never
been to a white castle before that's
that's true
i have never been to a white castle
before is is it does it meet the hype
white color what the hype of what what i
don't know because i i i only know white
castles
that one movie right uh what was it how
would harold kunma or something oh yeah
and so white castle doesn't sell burgers
they sell sliders
okay right so it's like the tiny yeah
what's what's the difference between a
burger and a slice like a mini burger
slider is just like a mini burger
apparently right i don't know where it
comes from but basically they sell
sliders instead of burgers right but
like normally right like when you buy a
slider it's like you know
you go to some american restaurants and
i like me like you know like like my uh
chicken parmesan sliders like that
shit's bomb
don't say it like that parmesan
oh what do you
that hurts me hearing that all right go
ahead anyway that chicken like my
favorites are like chicken parmesan
sliders all right so it's like the
chicken parmesan then you put like like
some lettuce in it
it's [ __ ] nice but white castle
sliders is literally just
two soggy buns and like the thinnest
patty
in existence it's like paper thin
patties and it's like oh
that's like you can get like a pat like
a six pack of six packs of slime
it's like a six it is it's like they
they box it like a six pack of sliders
for like four dollars or something i'm
just like
this is this is true depression all i
know is that everyone i know who goes
there has like the shits afterwards
oh yeah yeah just like like to me that's
like
how on earth we've got to the point
where that's just an acceptable outcome
how is it how is it that like americans
have gauged like the the tastiness of
a fast food joint by how much this
stomach is just destroyed the next day
yeah
you know what people are like oh yeah
it's not a good chili's meal unless i'm
[ __ ] myself constantly the next day
i feel the same with indian though
like i i i have to destroy the toilets
sure after a good indian soil
but at the same time i can only do it
like at most once everything
like a burger shouldn't do that yeah
indian i've always accepted that indian
does that yeah because of the spices
it's just like bread and meat what is
happening like what what what when
it's the oil yeah okay you know also the
most egregious thing that i hate they do
is that they put the grease on top of
the burgers yeah that's disgusting yeah
yeah who did this and who who likes it
because
i remember going to steak and shake and
they did this to my burger and i was
like well i don't want this anymore why
would you do this it's like you took the
worst part of the meat which is the part
that makes you feel sick
have you put it on top why i remember
when i was staying at uh
sydney's like family's house in
wisconsin
and they got like a takeaway pizza joint
one day yeah and one of the big selling
points of this like takeaway pizza joint
is they had like garlic bread
and the selling point was that if you
put like a wet
a paper towel on the garlic bread it
would literally soak it
in oil and they were hyping this up to
be like
yo if you put the if there's so much oil
on this that if you put
the wet paper down it will soak it and
it'll become completely wet and i'm i'm
just thinking
how is this a selling point why why
would i want to eat this
that's like that simpsons episode when
like homer's trying to get like so
fat that he gets like the disability
like thing
and dr nick's like grab the burger rub
it against the piece of paper
if it goes see-through you can eat it
like i thought it was like a joke i
thought it was satire no
they literally like marketed it as this
garlic bread is so
oily that you can literally soak up an
entire paper towel
and i just think about it and i'm just
like i hold it in my hands and it was
literally dripping and i took one part
and one bite was enough for me that's
like the pure survival food because the
sheer amount of oil could like power a
lamp
have you ever heard of this american bow
joint called the heart yeah yeah of
course of course yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're [ __ ] i was
watching a video yesterday of this guy
who ate the the biggest one there which
is called the quadruple bypass burger
right and it's literally think of a big
mac but snapchat i've seen
big macs on top of one another yeah and
it was like i already thought that it
was like 20 000 calories as well yeah
this guy like demolishes it in five
minutes i don't know how the [ __ ] he did
it
but the part that got me was he was like
all right we're getting to the bun now
uh the bun by the way is soaked in lard
i'm like you oh you shouldn't you
shouldn't so no no
a piece of bread should not be soaked in
anything
no nothing should be soaked in pure
[ __ ] fat
yeah oh yeah also the the fries were
oiled in pure lard as well
that's disgusting like i i just get a
shake on top of that
i don't understand the appeal of that
that's just ridiculous it just sounds
gross it looked gross it looked like
something out of the alien movies like
yeah
i didn't want to put that in my stomach
why do people hate their bodies like
there's only like some let's say
cuisines you can only enjoy when you
want to like
destroy your body and that's probably at
like 3 a.m
yeah after like out of five guys yeah
out of five guys
or like i i can never eat a kebab sober
like something has got something has
gone wrong with me like something has
gone wrong with my life if i'm eating a
kebab i'm not
and i'm completely sorry no you know i'm
hella depressed when i'm eating a kebab
for lunch
all right i love a lot like a great like
burger with a bit of grease on it yeah
yeah and not even drunk me would pass
yeah right and the heart attack grill to
me is just like
there is no reason why i would want to
come here other than to feel healthy
like like and just look yeah because any
meal you have after
going to the heart of that group you see
the other patrons
and you're like oh i'm doing pretty good
for myself hey like damn okay maybe i
haven't changed yeah because i think the
the selling point of the heart attack
girl is that oh first of all like when
you walk in they put on like a hospital
gown on you
and they sit you in a wheelchair to like
wheel you in and
here's the kicker if you weigh over 300
pounds you get the meal for free
i feel like it should be the opposite
you should be like if it's like taxing
the bridge right if you're already fat
well you should be you should be
charging at least yeah
to force you to maintain this egregious
weight
you know i feel like the concept of a
heart attack grill is just kind of like
if you you hear it and you're like
this is like fiction right this is this
is from like some dystopian society this
is from like some george orwell
yeah you know right like this is how
this is this this is how they fatten you
up before they dispose of yeah exactly
watch these like 500 pound like
live videos oh 600 pounds yeah whatever
you watch it and you realize like most
of these people just have like trauma
like at what point do we like start
being like okay maybe it's not trauma if
he's walking into the heart attack grill
maybe that's a maybe like that's on him
you know what i mean like i think that's
going
it's like a beyond a point of like
comfort food and there's gotta be like
all right this is just his fault like
this is you know what i mean
because because these shows these videos
with like these 600 pound people do a
really [ __ ] good job
and making you feel sorry for them and
be like yo man okay yeah like his parent
died at like five yeah
yeah eating disorder for some reason for
some reason at the age of five his mom
was taking him to the heart attack grill
and that's the only way that she can
remember him and it's like
okay i get it i get it i sympathize with
you
but should you yeah it's like what if my
parents were like well they've just left
me crack it's all i've had since the age
of ten would they be like
would i be like doing crack but like
it's just comfort it's comfort food
food to me it's like there's a clear
limit to the point where you've got to
be like all right well
maybe i should stop feeling sorry for
you yeah that that's just
oh no i i never watched those shows to
like feel sorry
because i i've noticed i i watch them
and they they do a really good job
making you think damn like i guess
yeah they set up me that's the thing
they set up the they set it up as a sob
story yeah but what you're seeing and
what you're hearing is like the complete
two different things because i think
that you know
somebody was a little chubbier not not
nowhere near that level
like i get it i get how you can gain
weight but there's like a limit of where
i think that it would go beyond anything
cause some of these they're eating like
i don't know like [ __ ] 15 hot dogs in
the morning
with like cheese and chili on it i'm
like yeah i think i would draw the line
i think that's right
yeah well that's the thing right it's
like the thing that surprises me more is
is not the fact that
this you know they like complaining
about having all this weight problems
and then they
proceed to eat a whole [ __ ] box of
chilis right yeah but it's also just the
egregious amount of food that they can
somehow stomach i'm like
yeah it's just looking at it makes my
stomach just doesn't make sense to me
and
i i feel like you must like you must
have just grown up with this and because
every time i go to america i always like
the food portions in there we've talked
about this before i'm massive man yeah
i'm like i'm forced to like have to have
these massive food portions and like the
first week
[ __ ] great yeah after after a week of
staying in america
i'm like is there a salad and i asked
for the salad and what comes
and what comes out it's a [ __ ] forest
you know what i mean
like they're saying a [ __ ] salad it's
like six heads of lettuce
the amount of dressing is like the same
as the meal because it's like 1600
calories one of my [ __ ] rabbits i'm
like did you deforest the entire amazon
rainforest just to put on my plate like
this this is the
kind of like food portions we're talking
about here it sucks man because it's
such
it's so unfair because we like if you
get fat in japan i feel like that's on
you yeah yeah like but if you get fat in
america it's like
well everything was set up against yeah
like welcome to the system
everything was set up to make you fat
yeah yeah so it's like how the [ __ ] it
like it's not fair
which is why i like because like my my
diet in america is awful obviously
because of the food
but like also like i get to the point
where i want to
have something but something but
something not greasy
and especially like in the midwest where
it's like you know where it's like the
countryside there's a lot less choice
and a lot of
healthy choices up as well so you're
kind of forced to be
like hey you can have you you kind of
have to cook for yourself and if you
can't cook for yourself then you're
pretty much
[ __ ] you know that's why it's so much
harder to eat healthier over there
than it is say say in like japan yeah
but but even then in america i remember
i i went to the uh to walmart and i was
like okay let's get some healthy food
and it was really hard to find like the
actual like
stuff yeah the actual healthy like stuff
and then i i go to the next aisle
there's a whole aisle
this blew my mind of hot dogs a whole
isle of hot dogs not sausages
hot dogs and i was like this is insane i
thought there was only one type of hot
dog
i didn't realize that hot dogs were any
different from each other because they
all taste the same
hot dogs never taste any different do
you ever notice it when you go to your
friend's barbecue or whatever
and they give you a hot dog have you
ever been like wow this tastes different
from my hot dog
no no it's always like i put mustard on
it but yeah that's how you differentiate
it they all taste a [ __ ] sense i mean
it's all the different like
brands yeah and somehow they had like 10
rows
on a whole aisle of hot dogs i was i was
blown away i was like this is insane
i mean i think like like there is
difference in like sometimes it's like
filled with cheese and sometimes
don't do that i don't like that really
no i like that
no no no no no because because this is i
like it because this is because
because this is american cheese we're
talking about yeah that's not real
cheese
if it was if it was filled with actual
like real cheese then yeah i'd be a
little more i'm pissed off that they've
managed to infiltrate
japan somehow this is whenever you get
anything with cheese on top of it here
it's such a gamble whether it's
americans like
[ __ ] [ __ ] americans see this is
the advantage of not putting
condiments in everything i can actually
i can actually taste the [ __ ]
difference between a normal hot dog and
a cheese hot dog and like
yes because that is an important life
skill isn't it
yes i i know i can't differentiate
between 10 different brands
that's why if you just put condiments on
it all the time then it just tastes like
the condiments right you don't
you don't get to taste the sausages in a
different way do you think we're like
[ __ ] drowning out
hot dogs and sauce honestly it looks
kind of looks like it a lot of the times
this is christ i just if i gave you five
brands of generic hot dogs would you be
able to tell the difference between any
of them because i wouldn't be able to
uh that just sounds like a trash chase
special anime i mean i'm not that big of
a fan of hot dogs but
i mean i can what is like a food that
you could like if we gave you like
different types of it
that you'd be able to differentiate
not tap water i can i can differentiate
between tap water and like
normal water but not like everyone can
not say like
voss water i i don't understand why what
the
never heard of [ __ ] water it's like it's
like the really really posh water that
comes in a glass bottle
um you can see it on screen now and it's
only like the really high class hotels
and i've like i've sampled one before
i remember because it was like i was
really really thirsty and it was the
only
it was it was the only water available
and um it just tastes like
there is no difference between the
bottled water brands i'm convinced
and then when you watch how they half of
them [ __ ] get their water half of it
comes from the same [ __ ] place which
is just
the normal taps that all the people are
using in the area oh dude you know
what's the one type of person that i'll
never be friends with
when someone will take a sip of water
and being like oh this is hard water can
i get some soft water please
that i knew people like that i know
people like that in california
[ __ ] hate you i knew someone who
could only drink uh
a brand of humber which brand it was
made with avionics they literally
refused to use any other water and if
they used
boiled water like in like cup noodles
had to be boiled
evion can you believe this yo but i
don't i don't know man i i i don't like
tap water like i i i
i i have gone through a phase where i'm
getting laundry
on youtube and then this is what happens
man he's like only everyone for me
well i mean because is tap water
drinkable in the uk yeah yeah it's
drinkable in the uk right where i live
i've grown up where everywhere i've
lived in my life tap water has
sucked and i've heard about this
mythical good tap water that people
talk about sometimes conor's one of
those people comes australia bro we have
great tap water i i've i've always had
like shitty taps it depends because like
if you get it from a choir to me this
this clearly tastes like tap water
because like if i can taste
the sink in tap water then then it's
it's like
inferior water for me i don't want to
taste i don't want to taste something
metallic i don't want to
sometimes i i get the hard water thing
because sometimes i drink tap water and
i'm like i feel more dehy
i feel even more dehydrated than
when when i first drank this water this
video is sponsored by
rage badass champions tough bosses
millions of players years of content
regular updates do you like fighting
noble kings and dark wizards
i do joey you're in luck because raid
has all of that
for you you will uncover prophecies
curses
betrayals and my childhood friend raid
rage shadow legends so use my links
below to download raid yourself to your
mobile phone or pc now i don't want to
be on the topic of raids boys but what
is that tree doing
raiding ourselves what is that
who are those three champions next to
the tree jack is that sir nicholas
rain beast and frostbringer now
personally gentlemen my favorite thing
about rage shadow legends
raid is that it plays itself it has an
auto mode so if there's some missions
that are too grindy
you can just let the game play it and
did you know that you can summon
champions at the tavern gentlemen how
many champions as many as you want joey
really
so what's new in raid well let me tell
you this month
rey just released their biggest ever
update in raid
shadow the main event is doom tower gun
is that true
and what's that is it a tower with 120
floors i could barely contain my
excitement
a bunch of secret challenge rooms and 12
seriously
bad ass bosses that you have to take on
i cannot wait to rage shadow legends
those bosses
on top of that they're also releasing 14
awesome new champions just in time for
the holidays along with a whole host of
holiday events and tournaments there's
never really been
a better time to start playing and
here's the best part
the raid team are giving away a bunch of
new free goodies
oh my gosh gentlemen god don't get your
chops up yet
plus a super special champion to help
get everyone started in the tower
bulwark and not only that 50 gems in
xp boosters some energy refills and even
an ancient shard as soon as you get in
game you can find
my account here on screen right now so
if you want to go and even join my clan
perhaps
go ahead gamers and it's just that easy
gentlemen all you got to do is
click that link in the description down
below or as i like to say raid that link
in the description and i'll see you
gamers
inside thank you to raid for sponsoring
this video
i i feel like the the best time to
like really judge how good water is is
when you're hungover
because when i'm hungover there are
definitely different levels
i feel different levels of hydration
when i'm hungover because i need
i when you're feeling like [ __ ] and you
just want to feel hydrated again
that's when like i i i will stick by the
bottled water
every time over tap water i mean i'll
take tap water
i just drink a liter a liter of whatever
is near me oh dude like if if i'm
like if depending on how hungover i am
i'll [ __ ] drink a liter of toilet
water like any anything to just get yeah
yeah no that's what i'm saying that's
what i'm saying
right it's like it's like you ever like
turn your bidet on and go
i have seen a japanese youtuber do that
before oh
god and the world wasn't it didn't go it
didn't go out well
but yeah i don't know i guess maybe it's
because at least in sydney like out
it's like bottled water is almost
non-existent in sydney because
legitimately the tap water is just as
good as the bottled water
right and also bottled water in
australia is [ __ ] expensive it's like
you a bottle like that big is like
four dollars i only buy bottled water
because i'm out and i
can't just find a tap to drink well i
mean here right
yeah yeah no here like because you know
bottled water is cheap right it's like a
hundred yen
so that it's a little bit more
affordable but in australia it's if
someone was like yeah i'm just gonna go
to the woolies and buy a four-door
bottle of water what about water
fountains do you drink from water
fountains
i mean i drink from water fountains when
i
i feel like a lot of this has come up
from my upbringing because in thailand
you can't drink
tap water so i've i've just gotten used
to being like always blind
but like i i do genuinely think the
taste of tap water tastes like [ __ ]
where i am
right like i can taste the chalk where i
in japan
no in brighton in brighton i'm in japan
it just tastes metallic
it tastes really metallic and i'm not a
fan of the metallic taste i i mean i
it was nice in wales and it was kind of
meh in london and
here i felt it but in london it [ __ ]
sucks yeah london i don't know but then
like london are you getting that like
cholera [ __ ] dude
i don't trust the water in london
i mean wales is nice the quarry was
right next to me as well no i feel like
because
i i don't know how it is in other
countries but everywhere i've been to
where it's like a big city
normally i don't tap water tastes like
[ __ ] countryside
yeah yeah like if okay if you're in
hotel right and you're
and you're really thirsty do you go for
the bathroom water
or do you go for the do you go for like
the fridge
mini bar water well you pay for it yeah
no [ __ ] way am i paying for that one
no no i'm not paying for that no
i'm going straight to the tower no way
no because
that's the worst tasting water the hotel
bathroom water is like the worst
now dude that's where i draw the line
that's where i draw the [ __ ] line i'm
never paying for water in a hotel
are you [ __ ] kidding me that's
ridiculous it's like yeah i feel like a
hotel is the one place that should not
be allowed to charge for walls
like i mean you're already charging up
the ass to stay in though
i'm paying for a basic necessity which
is just like being somewhere and you're
gonna charge me for water
[ __ ] off yeah in a way i mean for me i i
genuinely can't taste the [ __ ]
difference anyway so if i'm like shout
out to the hotels that give you bottled
water for free
yeah shout out to the you are the real
g's yeah so i don't have to [ __ ] go
through your voss water and not like
just one bottle they give you like four
and they're like go ham man like we fill
them all every day the best is like when
you come back from a day out and the
bottles are like bad yeah yeah
yeah that's the good [ __ ] on the topic
of food so with it being christmas right
now and everyone's just had
their christmas meals and everything
like that what uh
what are your what are your preferences
in your christmas meals
because i i'll be honest like so so last
year we all celebrated christmas
together
and we had a hot pot and yeah about the
traditional
it was it was a great [ __ ] hot pot
but i ain't gonna lie
it just it just just felt like something
was missing yeah it's not that's not the
[ __ ] turkey and whatever chicken
okay i i will say this i think turvie's
turkey's overrated as [ __ ] man
i don't i don't understand the hype
behind turkey turkey
i i think turkey is just like an
inferior chicken it is it is right
like imagine chicken but just drier with
less taste that's just turkey like i
don't understand
why all the holidays you know what it is
it's someone who just got a turkey and
just went into photoshop and did this
it's like everything is thinner it's
just bigger i think if you have like a
real nice turkey like that's been like
seasoned well
you it's i think it could be no because
like the problem with turkey is that if
even if it's seasoned well right
you get you get the outer part and
that's nice and seasoned but then you
get to the inner [ __ ]
triangle that's why you gotta cook it
you're going to cut it in a way where
you get like the skin and the meat in
the same bite but you can do that with
chicken
yeah but with less price yeah yeah but i
feel like you can make a turkey like
skin taste better than chicken
i don't know it depends welling agrees
and you know maybe yeah but melanie's
american
okay so if you don't like turkey then do
you like any other meats because
sometimes my family used to do like
duck or ham oh my my dad would make like
a roast ham yeah like
i thought rice pork right i think
genuinely like pork is the best for like
christmas i know it's turkey's the
traditional and chickens like the backup
but i think we never did turkey at home
really i think a good [ __ ] ham is
just like
you can't beat that [ __ ] yeah wait
define what you mean by ham do you mean
like roast
pork or like we we did like uh we did
like a lego hand
you could do either like because i don't
really like ham
like like roast ham because i don't like
anything this is [ __ ] meant like
anything
i know like what's wrong with that like
kind of like a gammon steak
kind of like that yeah it could be
because i i'm like
i'm like not a fan of gammon that's just
like the inferior part
it's amazing it's literally it is
literally the opposite it is literally
the more expensive bacon
like that's literally what gammon is
i've never heard what is a gammon
gammon's like a way more like a meatiest
uh cut of the the pig oh that's normally
more expensive than because bacon is the
cheapest part of the pizza right right
right and it's [ __ ] and gammon's like
the actual bacon's the best part of the
pig
thank you very much you've been [ __ ]
brainwashed gone like you think that
bacon stuff that's how are you gonna
argue
argue
that bacon is not the best part of the
pit it's the most overrated part of the
pig
bacon bacon used to be like the [ __ ] i
literally know
i literally know vegetarians who have
been converted to meat eaters because of
bacon
i think it's just it's the meme right
everyone says bacon is like the best
food right it's because americans put
bacon with everything
it's because the smell of bacon there
there is nothing that can like match
this i
just think bacon is like it's it's not
that great like it just kind of tastes
okay just give me like a nice piece of
pork especially the american bacon [ __ ]
you
talking about american bacon is american
bacon is the best bacon it's [ __ ]
awful it's the best bacon like stop
clapping man
british back bacon is like the worst
bacon it's the best way to have bacon
like no i just don't have bacon because
right normal bacon is like 50 to 70 like
the american one like fat it's more fat
than yeah that i'm not saying it's
healthy
but i'm saying it tastes [ __ ] bad it
doesn't taste good like fat inherently
just tastes like [ __ ]
the meat is the best part no no no no no
there's no reason why it's more
expensive one thing the one thing i
don't like about bacon is that it is
way too overpowering especially when you
put it with other things like
if you have like a if you have like say
like you put bacon on a burger for
instance
a lot of people love that [ __ ] right
yeah but for me when bacon is on a
burger all i taste is the [ __ ] bacon
like i'd rather just ha i rather just
replace everything with bacon it'll
taste the same it's like it's like the
nicest
that you need
i like making my burger because i don't
need any ketchup or mayo or [ __ ]
whatever my burger
you don't know sauce whatsoever on your
burger no you're [ __ ] clown
actually like that's probably why he
likes turkeys as well because it's like
the driest [ __ ] bird
it is like water this water that yeah
i want my bacon to be all fat just give
me the [ __ ] give me the driest
[ __ ] burger
and non tap literally streaky bacon
is like more and beyond the better bacon
what the [ __ ] is street
streaky bacon is the american bacon so
like i didn't know how
like because whenever americans british
bacon is similar to
a canadian that's the way they say
what's it yeah to america
british bacon is just like half so so
british bacon is more like it's like 80
to 90 percent bacon right
there's like 10 fat on the edge yeah
it's like a thicker right yeah yeah yeah
and like as a kid i i would hate british
bacon because i would just like
i would just like eat the bacon pass
first and then like
save all the fatty part for later
because that was the best tasting
fat on its own and you're actually
disgusting because it wasn't even safe
it wasn't the fat part it was the fat
with like the little piece of meat in
there and then i realized that
american bacon is just all that see
american bacon is just like the best
part of the bacon
because actually like we actually had a
podcast where you were arguing about
food and then you sit here and tell me
you just want to eat fat
like you just want fat and i should give
a
and this man doesn't eat the crust on a
pizza right it's like it's like the
fatty part of a bacon is literally the
equivalent of how you've labeled a crust
on a pizza no it's the [ __ ] opposite
because the crust and the pizza tastes
like nothing
and the the most tastiest part of the
bacon is the fatty part
that's why americans have figured out
the the best tasting part of the bacon
because they've just taken the streaky
bacon
which is the the most tastiest part and
they put it all in one
put it all in one
because if it's just if it's just the
bacon part like i've talked about this
the bacon part
is just to me like pork is just vanilla
vanilla beef we've talked about this and
like the only part that's better
is the fatty part of the pores like pork
belly pork belly tastes [ __ ] great
and that's mostly fat
you got to eat okay okay i admit pork
belly's [ __ ] bomb yeah yeah that's
because it's like this
is cooked differently yeah yeah and it's
also not a very like cheap part yeah
bacon is enhanced
that's an expensive part of the pork
it's no it's because of the fat
it's because it's because of the fatty
content that's what gives it the flavor
yeah but if you just eat the pork
but pork by itself i think it's a shelly
flavor with more meat added yeah so you
get chunks where you get a bit like half
meat
and half fat right but that's like an
actual like richness to it because it's
chunky it's like an actual like black i
just don't [ __ ] with the taste of bacon
and normally pork belly is
not like on its own it's normally
included it's like in a broth or
something where it's like bacon it's
like
you can have it with other things but
again it just overpowers everything no
one makes a [ __ ] broth out of bacon
like that's just disgusting because it's
[ __ ] someone in america is like um
excuse me
someone's try that out please when we
spoke about the food episode and we got
really heated
like day or two after joe was like you
know what i can't i think you're right
about paul
yeah no i i thought about it because in
the food episode i agreed with gone and
said like our beef is like the best
but then i thought i'm like no wait you
can't cut so much with pork konkatsu
all you can do with beef is have a steak
it's so [ __ ] yeah like maybe you can
make a burger at the be
it's literally so limited pork you could
every single amazing dish you can think
about that normally has meat
is normally i'm talking about i'm gonna
finish jump over to the other side of
the fans here and say portland
and the fact that the fact that you
because the fact that you say that you
like streaky bacon over like actual meat
just says the reason why you can't
appreciate pork just
i rest my case your pork just tastes
like well done
well done beef and as we all as we all
know
nobody nobody [ __ ] likes well done
beef this man did this guys
[ __ ] texture did he make did this man
just say that
i'm getting a call right now it's from
the circus they want it they want to
know your address bro like what the
what what you're not a clown you're the
entire circus it tastes nothing like
beef what are you on about because the
good the [ __ ] best part of beef
is like the moisture and like it's
next next you'll be saying oh duck is
just a fatty chicken
that's all it is man it's like it's the
same thing right
how can you say that that's they're not
even remotely similar my god
i've never ever even the consistency of
the bite is totally different too
every chef who was watching this episode
just had a stroke anyone who was in your
corner probably realizes how much of a
[ __ ] clown you are
nah nah i'm i'm i'm sticky in my corner
beef is superior to pork this
except for is bacon is the most superior
part
out here i will [ __ ] with bacon every
day of my life god's out here literally
arguing he's [ __ ] like kiddie meal
preferences and food pretending he's at
the gourmet table like get out of here
man come on get the [ __ ] out of here oh
my god
yeah everybody go anyway go back to
christmas meals they're going back to
christmas meals
um i used to [ __ ] hate christmas
meals because my my parents used to make
they honestly they probably still do
[ __ ] awful gravy it's like jelly
ew yeah i feel like christmas meals
live and die by the quality of gravy
it's true because
i i used to eat all of the components on
their own yeah because i i refuse to eat
my parents gravy and the whole family
was like what's wrong connor why are you
doing it
it tastes good what do you mean i'm like
no the kfc gravy although not great
tastes better than this [ __ ] it's the
consistency anything that's jelly i
don't like
okay there's there's like a perfect
noodle right because if it's too jelly
it's it's basically like a solid it
should be
nothing more depressing than watery
gravy you know right you when you pour
that [ __ ] in if it splashes it's
it's too yeah like it needs to like mold
but not be like jelly like yeah
i'm calling you out mom i get a question
there for you guys do you guys like
eggnog
i've never had i've i have tried it once
i am not a fan we don't have eggnog
just turned around mainly do you like
eggnog
melon melon just sims for eggs you said
japanese
okay i never used to like eggnog but
then like two christmases ago when i
went home my aunt
like handmade eggnog right and you have
that with like uh
i just i just it's like do you like
custard
i okay it's okay it's basically think of
custard but it's a drink
oh god yeah yeah oh yeah yeah and then
and then and then my friend
introduced me to eggnog with a fireball
and usually i don't [ __ ] with fireball i
think i think fireball is overrated as
[ __ ] but
that with eggnog is like it's so good
i only like custard with like apple pie
or something right something like you
can have apple
but i think custard on its own doesn't
sound good i like it with the solid to
like help
well that's why you have it with the
christmas meal oh jesus christ
i've been trying to find eggnog in japan
because i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] i do
not
i i just doesn't sound good like it
doesn't sound good i'll try it right
that's the thing though like the word
eggnog is the least
like appealing sounding word you know
what i mean
it sounds like a dirty porn
eggnog my favorite porn
sounds gross i don't know i just
i i feel like because my family's like
mega british
christmas meals to me have been like the
same for like a [ __ ]
as probably this they were a thousand
years ago yeah just people awkwardly
sitting around a table being like yes
did you like your presents
i i did like my presents mother should
we open a cracker do you have crackers
in australia
christmas crackers oh you mean like
white people like yeah
yes yes i know you have white we have
people
we have many crackers you know australia
they're just british people with
attitude
basically uh like you mean like on a
phone cheese platter and stuff like that
no no the ones you pulled oh all those
crackers yeah christmas crackers
you made like like biscuits what the
[ __ ] like
christmas crap yeah with the ones with
like the little may leave do you have
those in america the christmas crackers
that you pull is is that
is that part of the american you both
pull an end of this cracker yeah yeah
and then and then whoever gets the
bigger half gets the [ __ ]
yeah it's like a kinder egg it's like a
kinder egg but
like but you pop it open and then
there's little things that like little
plastic toys inside and there's always
like one really [ __ ] joke
yeah and you have a paper crown yeah
there's always the paper crowns
america doesn't have this oh my god no
america doesn't have that yeah well
you're uncultured you'd pull one of
those they're overpriced they're like
ten dollars for a pack of ten
and it's [ __ ] and and it's over in like
30 seconds yeah when you're like five
you're like this is [ __ ] amazing yeah
like this is like death note levels of
like mind games but then
six crowns but then but then you realize
they're rigged in one end and then when
you start cheating you realize that
because
when you when you're the one who's
supposed to lose and you just grab the
whole thing
and then they pull and you realize it's
not happening you're like
[ __ ] i i've been caught out here i've
cheated okay uh do you guys have um
you guys have advent calendars right
yeah apparently in america it's not a
thing
is it not no i've heard in some parts in
a lot of parts of america advent
calendars are not a thing i hated them
yeah i never got them i never got them i
don't like the idea of being teased for
like 25 days on chocolate just give me
the whole [ __ ] it's
like it's not even a bar like like like
it's just like a small amount
like so to me like advent to explain
advent calendar calendars for anyone who
doesn't know so you get a calendar at
the beginning of december
and every day you can open up like a day
of the week
and you get a different piece of
chocolate white people and like as
as a kid as a kid i was just like this
is
as a kid it was just like the equivalent
of no not the red meal or just with
chocolate you know what i mean most blue
balls
like christmas song okay also when do
you decide to eat the chocolate is it
the morning thing or is it an evening
thing
i always thought it was the morning
first thing in the morning
it was like as a kid it was it was the
only time you could eat chocolate
first thing in the morning it was but it
always like threw off my vibe right
cause i was like why am i [ __ ] eating
chocolate in the morning
i don't know why i don't know why it's a
thing in australia because
it's christmas for us it's in like the
middle of the summer
you buy it and it's just like the you
can see the chocolate
kind of melting from like inside the
thing you just open it's like
let's go did you guys have like the the
the expensive ones are like the wooden
ones right there
never [ __ ] buy me the expensive
wooden advent calendars the
the traditional oh my god the
traditional wood like the traditional
advent calendars i've seen is like it's
like a wooden thing
and then you open this like wooden door
to like open the chocolate
my mom like refused to pay more than
like a dollar for mine yeah so she would
always wait until like
december 4th to get it
and i remember being like okay three
days of expiry chocolate yeah mom i see
you
i see what you're doing here i i don't
know if it's like a mental thing
but for some reason to me advent
calendar chocolate just tasted
better and i don't know why like it's i
i have exactly the same
opinions about easter egg chocolates i
have no idea
why you know why it's because it's the
same cadburys chocolate
as soon as you put it in egg format it
tastes ten times better to me i don't i
don't know why
i used to i'm not the only one
i used to agree because i had an advent
calendar like three years ago
yeah and i was like oh fantastic i'm
gonna be a kid again because i had one
in like three years
yeah and i ate it and i'm like wow this
is just [ __ ] like this is [ __ ] and so i
just ate it all in one go i
i put them all out on like december 5th
i grabbed them all out put them in my
hands
you guys have the ones where you're like
you kind of like it like cracks out like
a medicine
yeah yeah yeah yeah but it's okay
getting back to easter chocolate right
yeah
i think it's cause you're a kid because
i you know when you're a kid right did
they have these in australia where they
had
so in the uk they have the standard like
one dollar two dollar yeah
eggs right maybe you get a chocolate bar
as well yeah right
but when you're a kid you'd always see
the big egg right i'm talking like
like 30 40 egg that was like giant
and i feel like the magic is lost when
you know you can buy it
because i my parents my parents were
never gonna buy me
the thirty dollar they would never buy
me more than one x i'm like yeah you
don't need more than that
that's ridiculous like and so when i was
like two years ago i bought the big egg
right but it was reduced
for like 10 bucks yeah and i had i think
it was going to be [ __ ] like god tier
experience
came with its own shitty mug and two
chocolate bars it was just [ __ ]
shitty chocolate
it was just it was awful i was like wow
i'm the opposite and then i realized
when i put all this chocolate down it
was like 300 grams of chocolate
and i could have bought like inside hole
alright
for them to put it in a [ __ ] mold and
just [ __ ] sear it together you
kidding me because the thing is
logically my mind knows this but every
time it's
easter like even as an adult like now
that i am an
adult i just buy one i eat it on the
same day which
which is what something i could never do
before and then like the next day i i'm
in my local tescos or something i'm like
i go for another easter egg i can do it
and the thing is
crack another one and the thing is i
always buy like the cadburys ones so
they always have like the the chocolate
so it's always like cadbury's buttons or
something and i know
like i can taste that it's exactly the
same chocolate i don't know something
about it's
something about easter eggs it's just
like the right thickness it's just
it's just something about eating an
easter egg that just makes you feel like
a king
i i actually prefer the ones that were
like shaped out like a rabbit
yeah those are pretty good yeah those
are good
ones those ones like thick as well yeah
something
maybe it's not just easter eggs
something about eating hollow chocolates
that just
like just hit different in my mind i
don't know
i don't know why i don't know about that
one she i don't i don't know what is
wrong with my psychology to be like
chocolate bar get that [ __ ] away
hollow chocolate oh okay let me let me
nibble on this
i'm i'm curious is there uh the do you
have a worst or best christmas present
you've ever received
oh god the the best one i received i i
feel like
the younger you were the better your
christmas presents 100
dude back when i could like just get
like a bunch of shitty toys that lasted
ten minutes
like what the probably best christmas
gift i ever got was i got a game boy
advance
oh [ __ ] yeah when i was like five and i
played like the shitty like kirby port
that was like the snes game which i
found out ages ago it was like five
dollar game
this is amazing father thank you yeah
probably the best present i've
ever got was an n64 and i i think it was
more the experience around it because
uh so i was at my cousin's house and i
opened it
like remember when game consoles were
like the gods here of
anything you could yeah
yeah you know your parents loved you
when they got you a game person right
it's like i feel truly loved because
thank you mother and father i remember
my parents got me when i was i don't
know
i don't know when that came out you know
when the wii was like impossible to get
yeah or something yeah
and it was just impossible to get well
they were like all sold out in the uk
but my dad worked in germany for like
most of my life
so when he came back for christmas he
brought me it and i was like oh my holy
[ __ ] how did you get a wii
and then as we went to plug in on
christmas day yeah couldn't [ __ ] plug
it in because he had the german
block and then because like my dad
obviously just forgot to buy one right
and i
remember booting it up and it being like
like
the thing like controller warning
i was like
[Music]
or something i'm like what is this dad
dad that helped me and my dad can't
[ __ ] speak german so he was like i
don't know son what are we doing i don't
know
like i [ __ ] had wii sports but like
and there's some other sports i had some
game and the title was
german i remember i was like so [ __ ]
confused as a kid i was like what the
[ __ ]
is this i think i got the wii for
christmas as well actually now i think
about it [ __ ] was born man yeah
but you know what ended up happening
because it was when we sports was like
insane
the the the day we got up working which
was next day we we sport i couldn't
[ __ ] play it because all my [ __ ]
like older relatives are playing like we
bowling drunk
when am i gonna play zelda what the [ __ ]
this is my gift what the [ __ ]
and yeah god god no because i just
remember my
my like one of my best memories of the
n64 was just the first time i boost up
goldeneye with my cousins and it was i
think that was my first proper like
multiplayer experience because like whoa
four people can play at the same time
and we can play together and at that
time like that was [ __ ] mind-blowing
because the best four-player game back
then was probably like [ __ ] bomberman
or something like that mario party maybe
no because mario party wasn't out there
was it no yeah because the first one was
on n64 yeah yeah it's just one's on your
phone
um i remember we stayed up till like 4
00 a.m which back when i was a kid was
like
always
those endorphins are firing off oh yeah
oh my god dude i don't really get that
anymore
because you can afford everything now
yeah i guess so right it's like doing a
pint of cocaine
like seeing the ps like seeing the ps5
i'm like i know if i get it i'll play
like demon souls and be like yeah i mean
sure like yeah yeah because the jump
isn't that significant
ps4 games can load twenty percent faster
now yeah
epic man oh wow really exciting yeah
like like going from like a snes to an
n64 it's like
whoa you [ __ ] kidding me i can walk
in any direction
what up is forward
what is this analog stick the cancer
that is the [ __ ] n64 controller i
love it look at i look at that thing now
i look at that thing now and i'm just
like how did anyone think this was a
good idea
i love picking it up still i'm being
like god damn you ugly son of a [ __ ]
i i i feel it again and i put my thumb
on like the analog stick and i'm just
like
how is it this [ __ ] hard like this is
designed to give blistered how did this
pass the ergonomics test
yeah the moment i like put the thing
like put my thumb on the joystick my
palm just starts to hurt i'm just like
the memories of blistered palms doing
[ __ ] this on my
party too yeah you could get gloves from
uh nintendo yeah yeah
yeah because they lost a lawsuit yeah
because of that mario party won because
yeah
yeah calm injuries yes oh yeah yeah my
my destroyed
the first day on the job they just took
like an ergonomics book and just set on
fire
okay we're designing the n64 controller
now guys is it fun
put it in man i remember as well that
same christmas when we got the wii
my older brother got like uh not the
death star what's the other big
battleship in star wars the one that's
like a [ __ ]
like that oh the the yeah something like
that
and then he built it all and for some
reason had the amazing idea to put it
near the tv in front of where we were
with the wii and yeah i'm sure you can
imagine what happened
oh yeah he [ __ ] hit the roof someone
did the bowling through it slammed the
roof smashed down and destroyed this
thing did he spend like eight hours
building
it was so funny i'll never forget that
[ __ ] watching watching my dad playing
wii sports is probably the funniest
thing i've ever seen in my life because
boomers get so into it oh dude like he
was so
into [ __ ] wii boxing as well it's
like of all
of all the ones it was the [ __ ] joke
and oh my god just watching my dad just
[ __ ] doing this for like two hours
it's just oh
so funny man i remember one christmas i
don't know how old i was
so i was in sunday school mm-hmm and i
[ __ ] hated sunday school because why
why the [ __ ] would i want to go to like
i i to as well when you're like eight
i didn't understand why i cared about
why i should care about
jesus and [ __ ] right to me i was like
who is this guy and why do i care
right yeah or or who is this guy who's
man
who's the big j man that everyone keeps
talking about man and so
i i remember this i [ __ ] hated it my
parents for some reason
because my parents right they i not to
out my parents here right but
they they wanted they said they were
religious my parents are [ __ ]
they just wanted to be real yeah it's
literally like i feel like the white
suburban family it's like we're yeah
we believe in jesus yeah we love j-man
yeah we love him man we're all
you know my you know whatever and i'm
like we don't [ __ ] release you're
just like
you know i actually yes my mom and dad
was last time when they went to church
and it's like
how many decades 1972 right so they put
me they had the genius idea to put all
of me and my brothers in sunday school
and my older brother he never complains
about stuff he just gets on with it
right right and
me you know me i like to complain okay
before before we get into your story
okay what is sunday school oh do you
don't know okay true
it's like a church school right so yeah
it's like i mean it's in america as well
i think it's more popular in america but
in the
uk as well it's normally like christian
stuff or catholic or whatever what'd you
learn in sunday school i've
because i've never been to san diego
jesus i i just know
about sunday school so i think i was too
young to do like the super religious
stuff
so 90 of the time they just spoke about
like religious they would tell stories
and i'm being like who the [ __ ] cares
and also i remember coloring in so many
pictures
so many [ __ ] pictures and i remember
when did you have like a jesus coloring
book yeah we had like a jesus coloring
page and i [ __ ] hated it because i
was like
i was like who is this guy why do i care
why am i coloring this guy
this is the fifth time we've colored in
his birth do we really need to keep
coloring
i do remember being like and also one
time and it was
you know i'd watch tv shows you know
american cartoons and they had like the
paddling balls
and i have this very very vivid memory
yeah one time one of the kids bringing
in the paddling balls and it was like
the coolest [ __ ] thing yeah
yeah and they immediately took it away
from him and i was like no
i want to play with the paddling ball
why did i take away from him i don't
know because it's jesus time
no one interrupts jesus and they made us
do like a play at christmas when i was
like eight or nine
oh well of like the birth of jesus yeah
yeah i
and i remember being like mom you're one
of the wise men yeah i was one of the
wiser
oh man you got you got a you got a big
role i was the snowman
but i think it was because that was
literally what i did
i i i literally just did this on stage
my mom still has pictures being like
great performance
great performance i think i was one of
the wise men only because
i there wasn't enough kids to fill the
other world
because there wasn't enough kids in this
school i i hated it i remember and then
also i was like why do i have to have my
mom
he's got gold i want gold that's
[ __ ] and i didn't know how to say
murr at the time when i was a kid
gold i know gold mother come on give me
it
and i remember we had to do this shitty
play and i was like i hate this so much
i hit it
and so for one christmas i asked my mom
i was like she was like what do you want
for christmas
i did i slipped her in the eyes and i
was like i don't care about gifts just
please don't make me go to sunday school
i i want my sundays back mom i'm going
to school five days a week
and then another day after turn up and
[ __ ] color pictures of jesus
are you kidding me i hate this [ __ ] and
i think honestly that's the reason why i
just care for like zero religion now
right because they pushed it so heavily
on me and i'm like this is [ __ ] it's all
a bunch of nonsense yeah yeah yeah we're
reading book stories about this dude who
i don't give a [ __ ] about like there's
no concept
so you went to you went to a catholic
school as well no it wasn't it wasn't a
catholic school but they did make us
pray
three times a day wait so what what so
in wales like a lot of schools should
make you pray
oh because it's just like a religious
culture even if it's like an atheist
like school
there's no atheist school it's just like
it's a school and a lot of them have
like it's just a school yeah in my
uh secondary school and my primary
school i think you pray three times a
day
oh wow but the thing is right that you
realize
maybe like in high school you're like oh
they can't they won't they don't tell
you off
if you don't pray because they can't
right because it's a religious thing but
it's a school
it's still like a school rule well no
it's like a school suggestion it's like
a cult right because
when you get in this thing right you go
to school and then everyone suddenly
bows their head and starts [ __ ]
speaking in tongues right they're like
oh [ __ ] okay i should probably join in
on this
left out but then you realize after all
oh
they're not going to do anything if i
don't pray and just stand there and look
around and be like what's going on you
see
all the other kids and so i would i
would just refuse to do it eventually
because i'm like i'm not praying
even this nonsense all right i don't
understand why they made us do it
because we weren't a religious that's
the thing it's like i i find that a bit
weird because it would make sense if you
went to like a christian school or
catholic school
it might have been like i it wasn't
officially a christian school but i
think a lot of the schools in wales were
like
christian or something i i think just a
lot of schools in england are like that
yeah anyway because uh i like i don't
think i went to a catholic or religious
but we still had to like we still did
religious things around christmas time
and i know i had no idea what the [ __ ]
was going on yeah [ __ ] because like i i
come from a buddhist family
so like we'd have events in the church
and stuff like this
i'm like what this is this isn't the
temple what is this
god we've just like sing like welsh
hymns and they're like the [ __ ] worst
thing i i had to sing hymns as well i
had
no idea what they were what they were no
there was one and like it was called
like dwarven men
[Music]
so every time they would like because
there was a sheet of twelve hymns and
they would never do
draw never men because everyone would
always like
look at each other and giggle and
because like the chorus was just
shouting like
like loudly daughter men like
they would never pick it because
everyone would just start screaming [ __ ]
on my head
in welsh because they found it because
they're all [ __ ] kids
and every time they'd pick it it was
like a [ __ ] event because every all
the kids it was the one time where all
the kids who didn't really sing and go
in and
would start would proudly say like boys
in queue right
yeah that's weird because like i went to
my high school was like a catholic
school
even though i'm not catholic personally
but like we didn't even have to do like
the whole like praying thing like we
would have to do you know maybe like a
like a like an end of uh end of term
mass or like a beginning of term masses
yeah yeah that's like
bring on the new year but yeah we never
had to do anything i i did it was one of
those things that when you left you're
like
that was weird wasn't it that was that
was weird that they made us pray
we would like pray before every meal and
stuff like that yeah like that's a bit
weird
yeah it is weird what's up with that
whales man come on and eventually my
parents did
grab my christmas wish and oh really oh
really got you out of there because i
literally
at what age at what age [ __ ] it was
before i started secondary school so it
must have been
how long were you in there for uh i
think like two or three years please
[ __ ] sound like a prison
i don't know what you're in there how
are you in oh i literally readjusted
this society now
the amount of times i was like mom i i
cannot i know you think that's just me
being a [ __ ] kid but i [ __ ] hate
this
please please take me out of this
honestly as a kid
like anything religious was just the
most boring thing for me like i remember
whenever my mom would take me to temples
and everything to go like pray and like
talk to the monk and everything and
like i i just wanted to go home and play
in 64. honestly yeah yeah like i'm just
like this
what's fun to do here there is literally
nothing fun to do here
in this religious place this is why like
when you see like those uh
families who like their kids just get
like indoctrinated into the
indoctrination of something like
raised into the i think it's
indoctrinated in doctor i think so
like they call like they're super
religious people right because i
remember even when i was like eight and
i would hear these things like
he turned wine into water and i remember
being like it's all like diddy though
i've never seen anyone do that um
actually
same thing with santa claus like my
parents would try and tell me at like
age 10 that santa was real i'm like i'm
not having any of that come on
come on reindeers i can fly come on
that's the question at what age did you
figure out that spoilers alert uh santa
isn't real
oh dude i i've like went on like a like
an
operation at like midnight to like find
out
like the stealth music to prove to them
that i knew
what they were doing and i found out i i
found out accidentally
because i think i was maybe like 10 or
11
and it was christmas night and i was
like [ __ ] i really need to pee i drank
too much
whatever and i got up in the middle of
the night my dad was like
this next to the tree and he just caught
me right handed and he's like
all right son it's time you found out
it's time it's time it's time you knew
the truth you got me kid
i i think i i know where because you
know i i
i did like a thorough sweep of the house
yeah
but you know a few days before i'm like
yeah there'll be presents here if you
know
yeah my theory is correct my hypothesis
couldn't find any presence in the house
and i was like
they must be hidden in the garage so i
was like all right i'll wait i'll wait
till
till midnight and on christmas until
they bring them in and uh
as a i slept right it was like covert
ops just pretending to sleep
my parents came in to check while
sleeping yeah and i i wasn't
all right so i don't remember the exact
age i found out like santa wasn't real
but i remember as a kid i was like the
smartest dumb kid in existence because i
i
i was i would like be figuring out all
these like logistics of how santa
could be able to send these presents
around because there would be there
would be years
where you know i wouldn't be at home so
i'd be like
how's santa gonna figure out i ain't
hungry
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so so so so
like we'd be saying at my cousin's house
right and the presents would still be
there even though we were staying at my
cousin's house no matter where we were
every year
and for some reason it just didn't click
to me as a kid
that santa wasn't real but but like
instead of just
realizing that santa wasn't real i was
in my head i was like
i was like yo so this is how santa knew
i was staying here so we went to our
house
didn't see i was there saw like the note
that i left
somewhere or saw like the phone call
that i had with my cousin
that we were coming around to his house
right so that's how santa knew that i
was staying around my cousin's house
and i explained this to my parents at
the time my parents were just like
yeah yeah you you figured it out you got
it you figured it out you've just
started he's smiling yeah you have like
the white ball with like the pins on it
does he operate my time zones like how
does how does it work
yeah oh [ __ ] hell i think i just
remember being like damn none of this
jesus stuff seemed to have happened
when i was 10 i was like i don't know if
this center starts real because not none
of this other shit's happening i want i
can't try wine
did you ever do like that i think it's
just like an american thing but did you
ever leave like the the cookies
oh yeah we did milk really yeah we
didn't do that yeah i didn't do that
yeah
i think so my dad just wanted food i saw
this brilliant uh reddit post stuff like
of like a dad being like so my son's
left uh
cookies and milk uh on on his bedside
table but
how do i tell him that santa is lactose
intolerant
like do i just drink the milk and take
the shits for my son well do i leave it
there and break his heart
i remember one time my dad was like no
no no connor santa likes beer
i'm definitely doing that to my child oh
my god
so he legit poured beer for himself and
then she drank it obviously you
bought a cold one for himself i'm just
going to be to my side i'm like did you
know that santa
loves gina santa likes a an espresso
martini
leave a gin and tonic and maybe a cheese
your platter will do i mean santa will
definitely eat the double of course
double shot santa doesn't like cookies
like brownies but like the special
yeah the special brownies give santa the
special kind of special brownies that
that'll do
because he knows that we'd believe it
like i i i believed that it wasn't real
but i also was like maybe a little bit
there's a chance that someone's drinking
this
well i mean santa is a grown adult you
know he might he's working hard
driving and drinking but i mean
that's okay so like
question to you guys do you normally
have like a normal like what's yours
what's your christmas day like what's
your typical christmas day
like do you have any schedules do you
have any like
used uh used to have uh you know you'd
open presents first thing which is
always the best part yeah pretty much
goes downhill from there
um do you remember the age where you
just couldn't sleep before christmas
and then as a teenager you're just like
dude like i've
well but i don't care about this you
know you realize uh when you were like i
don't know
did you always used to pick a lot of
things and you would get some of them or
did you get everything that you picked
i would get some of them because my
parents would also be like listen connor
santa's got a budget and i was like
really
so then i had to like look for the
product within the budget right right
and then i never connected the dots you
know from age like eight or whatever but
i would i would go through like
we had a thing called like argos yeah
argos
what's that it's like a they had like a
giant like [ __ ]
gigantic booklet imagine the most
depressing store you can think of you go
you go into this store right yeah and
it's not a store it's just a store of
catalogues
so imagine like amazon imagine if amazon
imagine the amazon warehouse but it
would have like an amazon irl yeah yeah
yeah you would go and you could book it
online or back then you had to go to the
store and
take off the boxes you wanted yeah
according to like the catalogue that's
depressing
yeah it was but you know because the
cats as a kid though this [ __ ] was
magical because it had like everything
in it yeah so you would go through and
and you know adult now you realize this
was just [ __ ] overpriced
but you know back then there was no
amazon so you're like fitting it in the
budget
yeah because how you go through it is
because back back in the day you didn't
have like
you didn't really have the internet so
you'd have to order off this catalog so
you're going to this
arg or store and there was this catalog
that was like as thick as a brick you
could [ __ ] murder someone with this
with this catalog right so your phone
you'd go in and you'd flip to like the
index
so you could go usually
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah and and so you flip
through the index and go through like
the game sections and the toy sections
which was like which which was the only
sections you really looked at all right
um and then you it was just like free
pickings basically i never i never had
anything and then basically like
you know when i turned up christmas
morning there would be a few surprises
but most of the stuff that i wanted
would be there
except that one time like i said in the
cow said [ __ ] dad bought me
qriket tickets clearly
clearly expressed my disdain for cricket
but i thought i thought this is going to
change
genuinely like other than the game boy
advance i genuinely don't remember what
else i got as a as
for like from santa one christmas i just
got like all yu-gi-oh
like i got like a [ __ ] jewel arm
thing and i got like oh you got one of
those
yeah yeah i got one all my friends have
got one as well jealous we would turn up
to school and we would play yukio but
then they just stopped playing after
they realized
i guess santa didn't have the budget for
that for me
i feel like i asked for one year but i
just didn't get it i mean i feel like i
was like
[ __ ] this look she doesn't need that
yeah it's like i think he just got me
like a bunch of booster packs
here's the graveyard and the fold-out
thing in the back of the booster pack
yeah he'll be all right i remember for
me it was always video games i never
asked for anything but video games and
that was because
as a kid there were only two times in
the year when i could get new video
games right
and one of them was my birthday and the
other one was christmas yeah it was a
[ __ ]
rare occasion if i managed to get a game
yeah on my birthday or christmas yeah
exactly
yeah so i remember it it was like the
highlight of my year because i'd be like
finally i can play something other than
super mario 64 for like this
like millionth time and so i but i
couldn't get every game so i know
i normally get like two if i if it was
like a [ __ ] special yeah yeah it was
like
i knew my parents loved me when i got
three videos yeah three games was like
the limit for me is yeah yeah yeah
that's like a hundred hundred quid 120
pounds yeah yeah yeah pushing it
yeah so i mean that's that's probably
why i will always remember the n64
because the n64 was just like like god
mode yeah
like i had never gotten a bigger present
in my life at that moment yeah now that
you say that i think i remember why i
wanted to like why i kept doing like
chess stuff and being good at
things because my parents buy me [ __ ]
if i wanted things they would buy me
stuff so i should just win the stuff
that i'm good at and they'll keep buying
me things
because whenever i like win a tournament
or whatever they'd go and buy me a game
and i'm like stonks let's just let's
just get good at something
i think that was me but just with like
school and like especially like japanese
for me like if i if i did well in like
my japanese tests and what not my mom
would be like yes that is my brother was
always better so it didn't matter i was
like i gotta find another niche oh fair
enough fair enough
do you have any family traditions at
christmas we just have like family come
over and you know
we have we have like two parties we have
like one like christmas eve so like 24th
of the night we would have kind of bring
all of our like family friends
over yeah so like all my like uh
childhood friends and one on like friend
like
friends from school and whatnot come to
ours and then christmas
day the next day is when it's like
family like during the day
for for me it's the uh for me it's the
other way around like family day
is like uh it's it's like it's like
completely sober it's it's like
christmas day boxing day is when the
[ __ ] party is at
where we get like drunk with the family
boxing days recovery day for us
boxing days like we've had two parties
back to back we've got to recover
i just have like family come over i
think and just have a nice little get
together
yeah it's nice for us as well because at
my parents place we have like this
because it's during the summer in
australia we have like this big
we have like at our place with this like
big backyard like deck
that looks over right uh everything and
so like just crack open a cold beer
in like the [ __ ] 30 degree summer on
a christmas it's [ __ ] like i keep
forgetting that that's weird to me
oh we go to my uncle's place and we jump
in his pool and we're just in the pool
all day on a christmas day it was it was
super weird for me like two three years
ago when i was living in thailand and we
were celebrating christmas in thailand
yeah and it was just like yeah
30 degree heat and us opening crest
christmas presents under a christmas
tree
and i'm like this isn't very christmasy
i'm just sweating
this isn't your very christmas see i
have to put the ac on yeah
it's just not it's it's i mean okay have
you ever had a white christmas
yeah i've had it once i've had a warm so
my family most the time
uh prefer to like go on like vacation
mm-hmm for
christmas i think they're just they just
love going on vacation
and there's something they always used
to do is like we're not going to buy you
stuff we're going to take you places
which which i appreciate now i [ __ ]
hated it right i'm like i don't want to
go to [ __ ] france mom
i [ __ ] hate france everyone in france
is a [ __ ] can you just get me
something new
you don't see family on christmas so it
depends on it's like i think every other
year
it's really like so we would sometimes
go skiing or snowboarding which
sounds [ __ ] pretty yeah yeah your
family have the right idea man
they are big brains but you know when i
was a kid i'm like i don't want to
[ __ ] be away this is my time off
you're making me do work
because to me right skiing with and
snowboarding my family was like a chore
when i was a kid right because they're
so
[ __ ] slow right i i would have to
like go on a ski thing and i would just
be like
i would wait at the time come on
peasants yeah i would i would wait at
the top and i'm like just go ahead i'll
be down
i'll i'll follow you and i would wait
five minutes on my phone and then when i
was like
it's been five minutes time to go like
full speed down and yeah and like
overtake them yeah
and then i have to wait and then you
know also when you're a kid and you
don't have money
i'm [ __ ] hungry as [ __ ] and in these
results because like we would go on like
packages
right so they were pretty cheap like
nothing
bashed my pants i'm very grateful but
they were like the cheapest possible way
that you could go to like italy and ski
right right which is fair enough i
i mean i applaud the effort but when you
had to eat out at these places they like
charge a lot for like food and drinks
oh yeah so like we're getting one meal
between us all we're all going to split
it and i'm like [ __ ] mom i'm
starving like i would i would nut for
more than one-sixth of the pizza right
right right please but going now as an
adult i have my own money
i'm like i'll waste all my money on the
food there i don't give a [ __ ] i want to
be full no because like these activities
i i've realized
the reason we enjoy them so much as an
adult do you do with your friends yeah
no
no no not just that but because we can
get alcohol involved yeah
like you know what i mean like it's it's
just like going on trips and everything
it's just it's just funner with a pint
and uh like oh no i guess yeah because
what you do after you have your fun
activity you just want to wind down
as a kid you have [ __ ] nothing to do
but as an adult you can just
get drunk with the boys and that's yeah
i enjoy spending more time with my
family now that i'm an adult than i did
when i was a kid yeah exactly
yeah because i've i've worked at i've
had three white christmases and all
three of them have been because i was
working at a ski resort in japan
i'd say having a white christmas in
australia oh no no
that's that's the difference that's
coming that's a different type of white
christmas
but yeah like the like i had the the
whitest christmases in like ski resorts
because it's just [ __ ] white
everywhere but like
the only difference between the
christmas night at a ski resort and
every other night is that
there's just more white people outside
really that's the only difference
because like
because what do you do at a ski resort
other than skiing and snowboarding
you get shit-faced yeah that's the only
sauna sauna's normally a good champ yeah
or like onsen right
but like other than that it's like the
only other thing if you if you wake up
in the morning you're like oh man my
body's feeling a bit sore i don't want
to go skiing or snowboarding
there's nothing to do during the day
other than to go to the one bar that's
open 24 7 and just get [ __ ] first
and also because like [ __ ] skiing and
snowboarding is so [ __ ] exhausting oh
yeah you're like all right that [ __ ]
pint is like amazing you even been
skiing
never been skiing i mean like
the the reason i've never been is just
because i i mean every every holiday
we went to thailand yeah it's also one
of those things where i feel like
i don't know why my family just were
like let's just go skiing for the first
time yeah i feel like normally you go
with someone
who's been yeah so they can be like i'll
i'll help you out yeah i'll you know
like skiing yeah also you know
when i was growing up i wasn't in the
most privileged position where my family
could kind of afford that because i i
feel like
going skiing is like an expensive
holiday or it can be yeah it is i mean
because
especially if you're in the country that
doesn't have like resorts nearby exactly
right exactly
right you know what i realized this when
i started flying for like conventions
and stuff right
i was i always thought that airports
were even worse than they actually are
because right if you get one of those
package deals the
company that does the package deal
charters the plane right right so you
all have to like wait in this [ __ ]
horrible line these planes are like the
[ __ ]
worst yeah and the people are the worst
as well it's like the worst kind of
british tourist
yeah which i'm sure you've all seen
videos of you watch like airport
meltdowns
it's always british people right always
dude these these [ __ ] flights are
awful man it's the most oh god you've
been on them
i've i've been on okay so the most
depressing place i've been to
on earth i think is luton airport oh
it's awful
or in uk in the uk yeah okay so we we
stayed okay so this
you know back back back before back when
i was just like
[ __ ] poor and all that stuff we uh
we we booked this holiday um it was it
was me it was me and sydney at the time
so we booked this holiday on this like
budget airline that flew out of luton um
and i remember to save costs we needed
to stay near luton
because it was actually cheaper to stay
near luton than to like get there in the
morning in the
like rush hour right right and so we we
picked the cheapest hotel
which happened to be easy hotel which i
didn't know
that already sounds soft okay so so in
like europe there's this
there's this budget airline called
easyjet it's the one right
and it's the worst it's one of the worst
airlines i wouldn't say it's the worst
what's the worst ryan i'd say right
orion is there both there's
two sides of this anything that flies
out luton is automatically like horrible
for me but like
um so we stay we're staying easy it's an
easy hotel and i've never felt like i've
paid to stay in a prison cell before
until i until i stayed there so it was
like we go in
and there's literally like no windows
yeah it's just it's just a white room
right
yeah no it's yeah i was just ours it's
just a black room and like the walls are
paper thin and they're like
i could hear at least like three
different people [ __ ] in different
places you know what i mean
and i go into the shower right that's a
shared shower right or is it
no no no you you had your own private
shower but it was like it was wow that's
one step
but like but like there wasn't even like
a door to like separate the shower
from like the bed okay so you so it was
it was just like curtains
so you open up these curtains and then
there is like
a toilet seat and then there is a shower
right next to it
and it just it was the like definition
of how i imagine a prison shower to be
right because the only thing said that
because
there's nothing separating the toilet
from the shower right so so you just
you're just showering
and yes and and so while you're
showering the toilet's just like
getting [ __ ] soaked yeah and
everything like that and it's it's got
like the gray
kind of like kind of like floor as well
so it
it felt like i was in a prison cell yes
and
i i had to pay good money how much was
it for like
a night i can't remember like 20 quid a
night oh [ __ ] hell
yeah yeah i would have rather say
like i just like i it was just like me
and sydney there but i was like
i better not drop the soap man i better
not drop the soap while i'm here
some dude just burst through the walls
like yeah
right ryanair and easyjet if you like
forget your ticket they charge you like
50 euros
i i got charged that when we flew from
uh [ __ ]
amsterdam to ireland i gotta charge that
as well did you yeah
i wanna i've never wanted to smack an
attendant in my life but when she said
that i was like
my hand is my backhand is ready yeah and
like if you have like over like five
kilograms or something which is like
what you're obviously going to have over
yeah they charge you like 50 pounds to
bring a carry-on
it's ridiculous it's so dumb it's it's
awful daddy because it's right in this
fine print where
they they tell you you can't check in
right yeah and i think that's the big
one i like i i
can i understand you know not not having
like not be able to check in
or everything but like putting it in
like the fine prints
that's just a dick move yeah it is it is
like what what is it like [ __ ]
designs yeah
that is that is it that is i they have
like a million ads
before you even get to you know what you
want to like get to like
the amount of [ __ ] renter cars they
[ __ ] try and show you is up the ass
online
and also yeah and also even if the plane
is completely empty they won't let you
choose seats and they on purpose scatter
you
so that you fought they force you to pay
to sit next to each other right right
but i'm like [ __ ] that
yeah no i'm not doing that [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ] i'll see them when i land
who [ __ ] cares
i'm not desperate that i need to be
within a two meter radius of my friends
all the time
jesus christ we have something like we
have something similar in australia it's
called jet star
and every every [ __ ] like continent
has that ah that's so bad i
[ __ ] flew jetstar once from sydney to
brisbane and it was like an hour and a
half flight but it's the worst [ __ ]
flight i've ever been on god
like delayed three hours for no reason
and then you get there and then it's
like 60 million years for the luggage to
come out on the other side i'm just like
where where is his luggage
it's like it's like uh you've been on
norwegian you've been on norwegian i've
been i've been on
[ __ ]
like compared to other budget airlines
norwegian is like the rolls royce of
budget airlines man
no it's because it's the only budget
airline there's like long haul i sure
and you can do you can have a 12 hour
flight and they will give you
no food really yeah on noise you have to
pay
for this oh yeah yeah but like and any
any budget airline that has
movies that has a movie choice it's
already
like better than percent of the fight i
think it only has movies because
they don't make those planes the ones
that do long haul without them built in
yeah i don't think they do that anymore
like so i don't think it's possible i'm
sure if they could have removed the tvs
and made you pay for them i'm sure they
would
but like the fact that they can they can
go 12 hours and not give you food
like blows my mind i've never been on
norwegian nail and don't that long
yeah i mean i i'd say i've i've been on
worse and and also it's a 12-hour flight
ride and they try and they charge you
for like a carry-on where we where the
[ __ ] were you flying to la to uk
uk and it's always norwegian because
they were by far the cheapest
you guys didn't have like american or
united are there's america yeah okay but
they were they were more like
double the price also broke as [ __ ] so
it was like either norwegian which was
pretty consistently always like 400
bucks
yeah return yeah jesus from uh london to
l.a and then the next stop was like
united which is like 500. but back then
it was like 100 bucks i was like that's
a big deal
like that's like a slightly better hotel
it wasn't 400 to 500 it was like 400 to
600
600 700. yeah i i think you got what you
paid for
um i i i think that norwegian is good
for the price
and if you're like if you're like a
someone broke
who's trying to go to like ax or
something or trying to go to la for
four years it was super serious it is
but it was just like everything you just
run the risk of you know dying of
starvation
every single time i was on the plane i
was [ __ ] hungry just eat a [ __ ] ton
before you get on
bring a [ __ ] ton of snacks and you'll be
good you just have to fast
the first time i didn't know i didn't
know that because i saw that you could
pay for a meal
but i was like oh they'll give you like
a snack or something yeah
nothing you'll get anything you get
nothing would you like would you like
this granola bar for
six dollars these chairs are the i don't
know how
it's like they've engineered these
chairs to be [ __ ] god-awful
like at least other airlines have
semi-competent chairs but for some
reason on norwegian airlines they'd
[ __ ]
handcrafted this [ __ ] to be disgusting
and painful
and if you get in the middle row of the
four it's like just just give up on
being happy in life for the next 12
hours
and one time i went on it and there was
a i was on the i was in the
the end the aisle seat of the three okay
well it's not the middle of the four so
i'm happy and this couple were like
making out next to me
and i'm like i swear they were fingering
each other because i was like this is
disgusting
like i wanna i wanna i wanna die please
please and no amount of like don't look
at the side could like
focus me on game of thrones season four
of the [ __ ] i was watching i was like
please
please please yeah because it's like
it's the one time you curse that you
have a periphery right yeah because the
one every time i would take my headphone
off you for a second i could hear like
oh i'm like oh god oh why
tell you what if you're gonna go on at
budget airlines just pay 300 bucks for a
good pair of noise-canceling headphones
like
honestly like that's the best advice i
can give you don't cheap out on them
jesus christ
like i don't know what it is about the
airplane design of seats
that are just like ergonomically
designed to be the most
uncomfortable thing you've ever sat on
did you see those standing seats they
were trying to make
it's like to fit more people in they're
trying to make standing seats
for airlines so that like they can fit
more people it's basically like this
at this at this point what's the
difference between that and just being
cattle you know what i mean
like would just be literally being
herded in
obviously was the budget airline just
trying to do this it's like [ __ ]
sardines
yeah yeah they were like we could fit 20
more passengers in the economy if we
if we yeah but but no one wants that
yeah because no passengers
because their argument was something was
that if it's a two-hour flight you can
stand for two hours
not but no i don't want to no no no no
no it's terrible it's [ __ ] what's
that
i don't mind a one-hour flight i'm like
whatever but like when it's 12 hours
sometimes having a bad season
even a prison transport system has seats
guys come on they do
the prison bus you can sit down yeah
yeah come on now
it's yeah it's sad man yeah but the
point was is that yeah now that i'm
older i'm grateful that my parents took
me on
vacation but when i was a kid now i'm
older i'm glad i have disposable income
yeah back to the thinking back to the
broke uni student days you know what i
mean
going back to christmas did you ever
have like
any christmas movies or like stuff that
you'd watch
i know i never got the concept of
christmas movies or did it holiday
movies i don't know like my dad
is like such a [ __ ] film i hate it at
the moment he hears the word christmas
movies he's like
get a [ __ ] away from i had really i had
relationships where they would want to
watch
[ __ ] around that time they would just
be obsessed with watching the same
[ __ ] movies and i'm like i don't want
to watch
i'm i am currently in that relationship
right now oh
[ __ ] man i'm like you know what
disney movies are fine but can we not
watch just disney movies can we just
watch something else oh i'd rather that
than the shitty live-action christmas
movies
like it's always it's always they always
have like the same kind of titles it's
always the same theme of like
oh it's a romantic comedy kinda but it's
also wholesome and by the way the entire
soundtrack to the movie
is christmas carol i have fun every
relationship i've been in they're like
yeah i love this christmas movie and
they put it on it's [ __ ] elf it's
always out
it's always it's it's always fun elf is
like the christmas classic
i was i was trying it's like the office
for like white people but on christmas
this is their video i was trying to
convince aki that die hard is a
christmas movie it is
it is tony she did not believe me she
was like die hard
the [ __ ] yipikaya one i'm like yes
the yipikaya one that is a christmas man
there there are two things that i know
that i will probably not get on with a
person
that if they if they say like if they
love disney movies more than like
a healthy amount or if they own a horse
those are the two reasons
there's the two ways i know i'm probably
not gonna get on with them some slightly
what is it what is it about horse speed
everyone knows [ __ ] skills are crazy
right now yeah
because they they're gonna love the
horse especially if you're in a
relationship with one they're gonna love
the horse
more than they ever love you yeah and
that's just like that's a fact that is
100
horse girls are just the equivalent of
car dudes you know what i mean
the honda civics in their profile
picture no no offense alexi but
no offense alexa
no but like i don't know i i never at
least with us like we never got like
especially with like halloween movies as
well it's like halloween movies
christmas movies
are there even easter movies is that a
thing they try to make that's not a
genre
yeah that's that's that there shouldn't
be a genre of easter eggs i don't know
christ passion of the crisis of an
easter movie
you know fun one time my best mate
his dad for his like 14th birthday got
him [ __ ] bruno on dvd
he had no idea what it was but his joke
was like oh i think you're gay son so
his bruno
what no joke i remember i went to his
house
right there you know yeah i was like
what the [ __ ] happened to this family we
watched [ __ ] bruno at like 15 at his
house
so confused with some of the things
that's just like the equivalent of just
like
here you go why are you gay why are you
again
you you are gay here's bruno he was that
one kid where his parents just didn't
seem to give a [ __ ]
yeah they're like yeah sure you can
watch porn i don't know whatever
who why are you hurting you'll get to it
eventually it's all right just just get
a head start
you'll be good sorry so [ __ ] weird
man so weird
like i i i don't understand watching
some of the christmas movies
but i do like the feeling of just
getting together and watching
a movie like it doesn't necessarily have
to be a christmas right that's that's
that's what i
like watching like family movies
especially on christmas my parents just
have [ __ ] taste in movies
wait what's the definition of a family
movie like a rom-com or
i don't know i mean i showed my parents
like wolf children with the family
oh okay that was like cool that was like
a very nice you know it was it was a
nice family
i could not get my parents to watch
costumes no no no no no this this was
something i had to like
slowly slip in the idea for years like
this is like this is like inception you
know for years to be
i would be like yeah yeah you you don't
just like
rock up in christmas and be like mom dad
i want to show you some animated titties
no you go you go
you gotta like plant the seed to be like
yo there's there's some like i
i could not get my parents to like no
matter what i do they would refuse
yeah my dad was like [ __ ] strict
about his movies because again he's a
[ __ ] film
so he's like the only anime movies that
i will like and enjoy
is akira and wicked city if it doesn't
have anime tits in it i
ain't interested because also i think to
people in the uk especially around my
parents age to them anything animated
equals for children
right like women should show them wicked
city i mean i'm sure if i did they would
yeah
but those are the only three movies it's
like is it violent does it have titties
in it
i'll watch it so there's no way it's
already a christmas movie though is
there no
i i don't expect my dad to be like hey
son merry christmas let's watch wicked
city like
i don't think that's yeah i don't know
like i i never got
the idea of holiday movies i just i just
never really
saw the point because because again for
us like christmas was like a time to
like celebrate with like family like
i mean like do you believe in the you
saw so called like christmas spirit and
everything like that
what do you think um do you think i
don't know because like
it's different it's different now like
but the only the only thing that's
different now really is being a youtuber
because like my like my entire life um
up until i became a youtuber christmas
was this like special holiday because it
was a holiday
like especially if you're in like an
office job as well it was
the biggest holiday you got of the year
yeah yeah and so
i don't know it was just like it i feel
like i got programmed into thinking that
this was like
just a special holiday and even if even
if i wasn't with family you know
something like watching watching
christmas anime for me like watching
like
some of my favorite christmas anime like
the disappearance of haruhi
was just like that that's something i
could never get bored of watching yeah
near christmas day i know you love that
i know you love
yourself like i don't give a [ __ ] about
most christmas movies but give me that
christmas anime man
yeah like i don't know i i never i never
chopped up i i never thought
ah i could watch it i could watch anime
i suppose it's weird for you because you
grew up in a country where it's sunny in
christmas you know
every christmas movie there's no concept
of like
grabbing a blanket and cuddling up on
the couch to watch yeah
yeah because you'd be sweating it's just
always [ __ ] cold in the uk so it's
like all right
yeah for us it's like merry christmas
let's turn on the cricket
that was it for us right i mean i think
that as i get older i think i i
appreciate the idea of it more which is
just spending time with family
especially because
i you know my little brother lives with
my parents and my older brother doesn't
live too far away
right yeah so it's not hard for them to
go visit him but for me it's like
because i haven't seen them in over like
a year i guess when i moved to japan
and originally they were like you're
gonna come back for christmas connor
like the first christmas was like three
months after i moved here like no i just
got here
yeah i'm not coming back that i'll come
next christmas i'm gonna celebrate
christmas with the boys
i'll come next christmas psych that
never happened so yeah i've seen my
family in like over a year and a half
now
yeah is that weird i don't know no it's
weird i mean it's weird and i'm sure you
would have seen them
oh i would have normally yeah i've
definitely seen them oh yeah yeah we
would not be here right now if if
the regular corona yeah yeah exactly
yeah probably probably would be back but
yeah that's how it is
unfortunately yeah unfortunately i i
guess as i get older it's made me
appreciate
you know that what it is is it's an
excuse to all right all right go and see
my family then come on
yeah i don't know like i remember like
like when
as as a kid and leslie as a young adult
i'm just like who gives a [ __ ] about
tradition
who really gives about the system who
really gives about tradition and all
this stuff but like
great growing older i'm just like you
know there is something a bit special
about keeping family traditions and
doing something special and like you
know it's it's
the whole christmas spirit thing is like
cheesy and like it's cheesy and [ __ ]
like that but
i will say like doing something special
that you do every year on christmas that
reminds you of
you know how you were as a kid and you
know the stuff that your parents
uh parents like bestowed upon you and
everything it's like there's there's
something special about that yeah
you appreciate i appreciate it more like
there was there was like i really liked
as a kid
didn't get it as a teenager and a young
adult and like more grown older the more
i'm like
yeah you know that's that's a special
thing yeah i also want to you know just
keep in touch with my parents obviously
and just see them as much as i can
because i just thought about i was like
[ __ ] my little kid's gonna be a little
[ __ ] if i if he's raised by me
yeah like he's gonna [ __ ] he's gonna
[ __ ] off the moment he can i better
better instill some values in him to
come back and say hi you know
i'm an old [ __ ] it's like my dad you did
the same thing
it's like no yeah because because i mean
like as a kid the the highlight of
christmas was the [ __ ] presents right
but as you grow older presents become
like a non-factor nowadays when you can
just when you have a displacement
all right give me the presents get me a
drink though right now my parents now
they're like what do i get you connor
yeah cause you know you you buy
everything you want and i'm like well
i don't know actually yeah i don't know
think of something yeah yeah
yeah it's like money can i say money so
so now that
it's not it's not a presence they're
just like a non-factor you've got to
have something to look forward to for
the christmas holidays that's right
that's true yeah
spending time with the family spending
time with the fans spending time with
the boys all the boys
yeah to explain what we did last year in
christmas we just uh stayed up till like
3 a.m watching super monkey ball speed
runs and it was
was [ __ ] amazing it was good that was
amazing
can we start that tradition
get the family around the world honestly
i could i could
i could start that [ __ ] tradition man
it is good man you don't know the magic
of super monkey ball speed runs until
you watch one
dude like especially when you're drunk
as well they're like insane like it just
defies gravity
and like just enjoyment they're really
entertaining
it was super entertaining but we also
watched die hard right before that we
did watch
out oh yeah we did we actually did watch
oh we didn't watch a christmas movie
yeah because because that was when i was
still naive and thinking like die hard
isn't a christmas movie
and then you guys were like no no trust
us because we're eating the hot pot
right while i played
that's right yeah and then we're like
let's watch a christmas movie die hard
and then we watch something like well
you know what it's
i stand corrected this is a christmas
movie it is it is a christmas movie with
a christmas spirit before [ __ ] bruce
willis just gave up on acting
yeah you've seen his recent films oh
[ __ ] hell they're awful really he
refuses to like do anything and he has a
double doing
everything you should watch some of them
dude watch out
hard kill watch that hard kill kill
watch that movie that sounds like a
[ __ ] die hard
i [ __ ] watched it and it's oh my
[ __ ] god because i watched looper
and i was like i just realized the
absurdity of that name
he he died kill he does like he does
like six movies a year and they're all
like straight to dv that's like a kojima
character you know what i mean
dude seriously watch these dudes it's
like a metal gear character right
in some of these scenes he's like given
so little [ __ ] about trying that like
it's just a dubbed over actor really
yeah it's so lazy it's just like let's
take two edgy words and smash them
together
like hard death knife hard kill oh
please
okay this christmas watching hard kill
and you can see how [ __ ] awful bruce
willis is
gonna say he's [ __ ] terrible because
i think the last bruce willis film i
watch was looper
and even then it was like i was like
dude
he's giving up you just give a [ __ ] this
guy's made his cash already like he's
just he's just did it now
why still dude you've made so much money
just [ __ ] stop yeah
yeah that one joseph gordon-levitt was
like acting bruce withers was just like
yeah you you can do you can carry this
one always turns up and it's just like
bruce willis
he turns up to the set and apparently
like all the things he does is like
right
he agrees to do like three days of
shooting right and that's it like no
more
no retakes really and heart anything
that physically doesn't require him
is a body double so even if it's like
getting on his knees yeah like don't you
get a bodybuilder
because he's too lazy to do it oh my god
i i did watch a uh
uh i don't know when it was pretty
recent but uh wyatt did like uh
bruce willis answers like most googled
questions he doesn't give a [ __ ]
it was one of the most boring wide
videos i'd ever seen because he he just
it was
monotone the entire thing is like
harrison ford when you when you can tell
that he respects the movie and a
director he [ __ ] tries like in blade
runner the new one he was [ __ ]
amazing yeah but when he when he's in
interviews he's like i don't [ __ ]
give a [ __ ] yeah but bruce willis is
always like that
like nothing makes bruce willis care
like he he literally is like the
angriest oldest [ __ ] in all of these
interviews like
you can tell he's like whatever i've
made my money i just
sat up i just turned up and said words
you know it's acting
like all right bruce willis [ __ ] out
guys could you imagine if youtubers get
to that point
i'd argue something i mean yeah i didn't
i didn't want to say
but you know some some of us uh some of
us are already there
not not us i mean there's some youtubers
already there god
i just couldn't imagine just still doing
it when i hate this like i just yeah i
like that especially if you've already
made your like [ __ ] fortunate name
at that point you're just doing it to
stay relevant yeah right
youtubers again yeah yeah well like
that's the thing right you don't have to
stay relevant
if you're like at the point of like
bruce wills like everyone knows your
[ __ ] name and what you look like
that's why like no okay and like no one
watches action movies and
that has like a big name to it and
that's why they get him because
they can he just makes up a lot of bank
his name has a lot of pull for action
movies and he just doesn't give a [ __ ]
that's true that's true i mean our
action movie is even like a big thing
nowadays yeah because john wick is i
mean like no i was
i was gonna say like aside from john
wick but that's the thing right if you
can bring it back and you can do it well
with the right actors like it'll be huge
like
you're talking about like you know ones
that aren't falling under like a
notable ip right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but john wick like hard kills
like john wick wasn't a notable ip until
you know keanu reeves made it notable
when did i week one
hard kill to me sounds like one of those
seven years ago i don't know hard kills
to me sounds like one of those titles
where
like so when i when i was in thailand
right that i would i would always have
this
like i i would always go to like in in
like southeast asia
there's always these stores that you can
buy like pirated pirated dvds
yeah yeah yeah and you'd go through like
you'd flick through the covers and you'd
be
you'd see these like the most random
movies of these like a-list actors
but you'd never heard of the film before
yeah that's hardcore that is
yeah but that is also all of bruce
willis his recent filmography
it's all movies like how is this man
doing eight movies a year how does it
happen how do you have time for that
i kind of want to just like go through
his imdb now just to see like have a
look at this
it's insane and it's like you know i
think that's the reason why and like
imagine at the time people probably
didn't give a [ __ ] about action movies
until like terminator came out and
probably at that time you're like this
is this is crazy what the [ __ ] like
because i mean that's not james cameron
directing it which i don't know like
80s was like a [ __ ] golden period for
action movies right right right right
because it was like the schwarzenegger
um
right claude van damme yeah i mean like
i could i could re easily re-watch
right like so many of their action
movies and that's also when like martial
arts movies also were starting to like
kind of
yeah because i feel like i feel like
before john wick there was this
huge period where action movies were
just not pulling in the numbers anymore
i'm just reading these [ __ ] titles
i've never heard of any of these yeah
because they're all straight to dvd
so we have so 2017 first kill
acts of violence death wish air strike
ten minutes gone trauma center survive
the night
i don't know any of that by the way all
of those are direct to dvd
yeah this sounds like all of them they
sound like a satire of themselves
at that point no one wants to hire him
because why would you he's just gonna
turn up and [ __ ] be lazy
and there's five movies right now that
has been announced with ximena that is
like
to be announced midnight in the
switchgrass bro we got a cosmic scene
all right we're we're watching one of
these on christmas man i got it because
they're [ __ ] awful we got to watch
him it's terrible
he's given up dude it's terrible oh my
god that's that's really stop making
films like why it's really watch one of
these on christmas and tell you how it
is
next time why why my god
yeah do you boys have any plans this
christmas like
i mean uh i i'm curious to see what this
christmas will be like
in the current world situation true this
is probably going to be the most
depressing christmas of all time because
christmas in japan
is like it's it's a bit weird because
yeah do you want to explain what
christmas in japan is like
yeah so essentially by kfc yeah
basically yeah
yeah christmas in japan is sponsored by
kfc basically it's like
kfc is the go-to place how did that
start
how did that start okay it's because i
did a video on this a few years ago but
basically
the theory is that colonel sanders right
looks like santa that's the theory
because think about it right think about
it christmas colors what are the
christmas colors red
yeah right yeah yeah what does colonel
sanders dressed up in red
right does it yeah it's a white suit i
thought yeah but the kfc color has
really great
and then colonel sanders is an old guy
with a white beard
kind of looks like santa right and i bet
if you trace that back it's like the
most
five-head kfc employee like working in
the marketing team it's basically it
it's it's it was a marketing ploy by kfc
to be oh it was amazing yeah
like basically yeah basically like they
were like well uh you know the christmas
dinner overseas in in in the west
is uh they have chicken yeah they have
roast chicken
fried chicken is kind of the same thing
right it's like you know it's still
chicken
yeah why don't we try this let's try one
christmas that's pretty cool we're gonna
we're gonna try and sell this hello and
it just [ __ ] exploded because
you can't get a roast chicken in japan
and also other than kfc out of
outside of some kombini's i saw this
there'd be a an employee dressed in a
santa outfit
yeah with a fried chicken like yeah
selling
fried chicken yeah yeah sell fried
chicken well they sell like cakes right
this is so [ __ ] weird what am i
looking at it's it's bizarre
looking at an asian man dressed in a
santa costume sami fried chicken in the
name of christmas
i'm like what the [ __ ] but it's also
weird as well because like normally like
everywhere else in the west right
christmas is like a family thing
right you gather like mom and dad grab
yourself japan it's like
a beta valentine's yeah it's a reality
it's it's like you go on dates
yeah you go you watch you go to the prom
that's that's
that's uh christmas here but that but
that part i understand
because literally a week later is uh new
year's eve right and new year's eve is
like a super like buddhist family thing
in japan
yeah so it makes sense that the opposite
of what it is in western yeah
it's like in western cultures like oh
new year's eve
yeah let's go see you next to your
parents yeah so
i don't know i just i personally have i
i mean well
this year i plan to go up uh north to go
see uh chris
um and uh we're gonna we're gonna go to
natsuki's place and have kfc
for christmas yeah that's the plan
that's the plan and i'm like man
first time ever i've been living here
five years first year i'm gonna have the
true
japanese christmas experience of eating
kfc i'll i'll let you boys know how
depressing it actually is
but uh having because it's not like i
remember before coming to japan
i'd heard so many rumors about japanese
kfc being like
the best kfc in the world you you ain't
tried kfc
until you had japanese kfc and then i
came here and then i ate it
and then it was just kfc yeah i
generally think the uk one was better
even
i thought the uk one of the better menu
it is the most meat kfc i've ever had
yeah
man i love the burgers the chicken
sandwiches that you get in kfc they're
[ __ ] amazing oh yeah
in the uk they're so good as well
honestly i don't know what it is about
uk or kfc's
it's good i mean i i feel that you guys
have kind of perfected like fast food
chicken with nandos right
i mean that's like south african though
yeah originally right but we just
i think every single fast food chain in
the uk has like fried chicken
options but as a not on its own right
like mcdonald's
i think some of the most popular stuff
they sell in the uk is like just like a
chicken select stuff like that chicken
chicken select and also like the wrap
chicken
yeah oh okay that's the best thing that
i get yeah that stuff is good
and every like every like dirty kebab
still has like the fried chicken option
as well
so there's just fried chicken everywhere
but like yeah
i don't know like because yeah british
is the best kfc japan is like summer in
the middle
and then america's america is just like
do i want to feel like [ __ ]
yeah kfc it is yeah i i don't know why
like american kfc just stopped trying
because it's not like america doesn't
have bad
fried chicken options it's just one of
their like some of their biggest chains
are just the worst in america
and i don't understand why i was drunk
one time someone gave me a kfc chicken
in america yeah and even drunk me was
like this is vile
and you know it's bad if drunk me is
like this is too much i draw the line at
the amount of grease
that's on this thing yeah like the skin
wasn't crispy it was
moist from all the grease it had and i'm
like that's vile sorry we somehow
turned this all around to bashing
america i love america i do i just
what's going on now
correctly case in point chick-fil-a yeah
chick-fil-a but
like that's why i don't understand why
anyone in america would eat kfc when
there's like
chick-fil-a or popeyes or you never see
good reviews on google maps
or for like kfc it's always like two
stars and i'm like who's willingly
going in here stop giving them [ __ ]
customers just stop
yeah it's sunday right and chick-fil-a
is closed
yeah that's true i mean not not all
parts of america have chick-fil-a
apparently
yeah no they don't do that east coast
doesn't have chick-fil-a or something i
don't know
there's like different chains like
different areas as well i know
but all i know is kfc's the worst fried
chicken
honest honestly now i feel like
christmas for me is more of like
it's it's christmas when i spend it with
the the people right so it doesn't have
to be on christmas day
yeah just around the time you know give
or take as long as i hang out with some
friends it could be like a week a few
drinks
you know just be like just let's just do
an early christmas you know exchange a
few gifts you know
i i i do want to do something on
christmas because there's
i do i've i've had like christmases
where i've done nothing before
and it is a bit depressing when you're
just like by yourself or
do nothing you go in your timeline
everyone's opening presents with each
other
just like what if you're having like
christmas day the next day with your
friends it's like all right whatever i'm
getting it
i think it was worse is new years alone
for some reason i've had new years alone
before yeah same i have two and for some
reason it's more depressing than
christmas alone
i don't know why i spent new year's one
year in the worst [ __ ] way possible
i think i was like 16 um and i was
working up at a
ski falls the first time i was working
up at a ski field and uh
we're in the middle of hokkaido in the
mountains it's like [ __ ] minus 30
degrees in a [ __ ] blizzard
and of course i'm working that day i'm
outside
in the [ __ ] blizzard shoveling snow
but on top of that
one of the hotels had a blocked sewage
system
and i had to get in there with a [ __ ]
shovel so imagine a 16 year old
right right in the middle of a [ __ ]
blizzard in the mountains
literally shoveling [ __ ] out of the
ground
like happy new year like 11 p.m yeah
right
and literally the moment we've unclogged
the thing my boss was like
oh the oh it's the next year yeah happy
new year
oh yeah we did nice but also it was like
cool
my first uh experience of the new year
is the smell of frozen
[ __ ] hey it's only up from there right
yeah i mean what yeah true
sure it was a good year but it wasn't it
wasn't the greatest start to the year
that's for sure
i feel like new year is like the biggest
hoax that everyone's put over the world
it's never as good as you want it to be
it's it's it's hyped up as
the biggest party of the year and nobody
knows what they're doing until the day
before i swear to [ __ ]
everything's full like you can't get in
anywhere everywhere's overpriced
everywhere is full everyone's doing
something
aside from you for some reason even
though you ask a week before
hey what are you doing for new year's
and they don't [ __ ] know yes somehow
on new year's you're that one [ __ ] who
just has nothing nothing planned
it's always the worst way like the last
day of the year you have the biggest
fomo of the year i mean it's like
it is always somehow i always more often
than not end up just
doing nothing like new year's eve always
being like [ __ ] i missed out yeah yeah
like yeah you might as well rename new
year's eve fomo party
because that's what it is that's what
new year's eve is everyone goes out
because they're afraid of missing out
because i've spent new years alone
before and it is depressing yeah
it's it's really [ __ ] depressing
shout out to the people out there who
are going to be alone but like
at this at the same time some of my
worst [ __ ] nights out have been on
new year's eve as well that's true
it's never a good night it's always just
so stressful because you can never get
like a taxi either
yeah if you need to get back because
everyone's getting tired it only took me
one year's eve of going out to know that
all right
next new year's eve from now on is just
house parties the only people who win
are uber drivers man they're the only
ones winning
church [ __ ] man i god news is the worst
[ __ ] i just realized how much i hate new
years yeah it's like gotta do something
i don't want to be
sad like you're either sad or you're
having a [ __ ] night yeah
or you're broke there's there's there's
no there's no there's no
there's no perfect new year's there's no
perfect new year's eve yeah that's true
like god i [ __ ] hate news
do you guys have any plans for this new
year's no no i'll figure that out when
it comes to it yeah
you'll figure that out on this one we
just said we don't nobody knows what
they're doing until like the day [ __ ]
yeah because everyone's like everyone er
they always do this thing for new year's
right where everyone's like we could go
here like everyone is always like yeah
which one is throwing suggestions yeah
everyone throws suggestions around new
year's but yeah no one wants to commit
to it because you don't want to be the
[ __ ]
who took them to a place that's full
right yeah right and then it's like well
then what like we're in we're in
because no one wants to commit because
everyone knows okay this place is going
to be overpriced and full
yeah um let's let's let's leave this
until like the last moment because the
thing is
there is no good place on new year's eve
but you have to go to a place
right like your maybe your friend can
get you into somewhere and then you can
only get like half of your friends
right and then it's like well what the
[ __ ] happening do we just leave half
our friends and tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves
yeah but and like the best the best new
year's eve part like party would
probably be a house party
but like no one wants to host a new
year's eve house party right
sure it's always like it's it's always
like a voting ballot that you just don't
want and even then it's like do i really
like everyone at this party
yeah like some other people because like
as
as like a teenager if you were hosting a
new year's eve house party that house
was getting trashed oh yeah
you knew it was getting trash and no
matter how small you wanted it to be
it was never going to be small because
it's a new year's eve
yeah but yeah because you don't want it
to be like because it's somehow like
reverse like depressing when it's like
too small three people
too small and it's depressing yeah but
like i like i swear like as a teenager
you'd have like [ __ ] sniffer dogs
trying to trying to sniff out house
parties man you're just like where can
we where can we go boys where can we go
because i've heard in the grapevine that
there is a house party somewhere around
here
you know you'd always know that one mate
who would know someone who'd known
someone who's like
who'd heard about a house party
happening yeah i've not proud admit
definitely spent the new years just
going to house parties that like were
just full and then not being able to get
into any of that right and then i was
like
i guess we're just going to tesco's and
getting a few beers and just sitting
outside
all right i've had some of the most like
depressing see
like trying to like house hunt a house
party right
and we'd just be literally we'd
literally be at like six
and like the time we would start and be
like okay who who
who's who's heard some rumors we're
gonna follow up on everyone
phone phone up all your contacts like
a [ __ ] l.a no gather clues yeah right
now call up all the favors you know
like because no no one wants to no one
wants to be that guy who invites
who invites everyone to the house right
but sometimes
you know i may he owes you a favor who's
at the house party you're like
yo just just give me the general
directions yeah come on the last day of
the year
yeah do a solo yeah well when if you had
a friend who just got blackout drunk
before midnight and it's like [ __ ] man
i've been there before you like gotta
[ __ ] take care of them now and you
gotta
[ __ ] i've had some new years where i've
like passed out at like 10 p.m
just like i see you next
those are the days man what a what a
depressing message to end this year
hey man if you're depressed on new
year's don't worry everyone is everyone
is there we've all been there
we've all been there but you know who
isn't depressed our wonderful patrons
oh my god look at look at these amazing
things thank you so much patreon
yeah you make me not depressed you you
gave us the real christmas presents your
patronage has made us happy shout out to
all the [ __ ] degenerates
who just like so we we are filming this
just
after the massive [ __ ] burst from my
hentai episode
um what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did you
guys do
that was the definition of stonks like
that was people like porn man people
like dogs brain
i didn't realize throughout my entire
five-year
youtube career like that all i needed to
do was to talk about
animated porn you know why didn't you
tell me this at the beginning of my
career with the amount of hentai videos
i've made i am
actually like the that jump actually
made me depressed
because i could have i could have cashed
in on that man but i did it
but yeah if you'd like to join us on the
patreon with lovely
rewards and whatnot then you can go over
to patreon.com
links in the description also check out
our twitter and subreddit as well send
us all your christmas and new year's
memes
yes fantastic and uh yeah this is share
us your best gifts and
everything yeah yeah yeah let us know in
the comments we don't know what we're
getting for christmas yet um so
shout out to patients yeah shout out
shout out to patreons hope you've had
a very merry christmas or like you have
to say happy holidays now don't happy
holidays
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes like merry christmas
hope you guys because it's boxing day
merry christmas and we hope you have
uh non-depressing new years wow
but yeah uh this is the last episode of
2020. yeah yeah and next time we see you
guys will be 2021 hopefully we won't
suck as much as 2020.
it probably will it probably will we've
set the bar so low i don't want to say
you can't get any worse right guys but
well [ __ ] at least at least trash tasted
good this year boys
exactly yeah exactly thank you for
joining us on trash taste 2020 see you
next holidays
happy holidays see you next year bye
[Music]
you